this video is brought to you by
betterhelp
what's up everybody helen here to talk
about a show so cheerful that watching
it feels like sunbathing in a field of
daisies
oh sorry got that wrong i meant barry
this hbo offering from bill hader and
alec burke is a master class in great
acting great writing and great directing
and the show just finished its third
season with the finale so stressful it
should have come with a disclaimer for
people with anxiety disorders so now
seemed like a good time to dig in here's
the gist barry is a marine turned hitman
who wants to leave his violent past
behind and pursue acting unfortunately
life keeps getting in the way and he
keeps having to do more murders to cover
up his previous murders really relatable
stuff for all of us if i were to cold
pitch this concept to you you probably
wouldn't guess that it would become one
of the funniest shows on television but
somehow it has i got a wife a [ __ ]
kid now look at this look oh that's
[ __ ] crazy he looks just like you
you know so what's going on are we all
secretly sadists has barry simply crack
the code on balancing brutal violence
with offbeat humor
we'll investigate in this wisecrack
edition why we laugh at barry and of
course major spoilers ahead for a show
you really ought to watch
but before we dive in we want to thank
this video sponsor better help if you're
feeling depressed anxious or overwhelmed
these days better help can be an
excellent resource for feeling better
personally i feel like all of the stuff
going on on social media and out in the
real world it just has me feeling
completely overwhelmed and i could
really use somebody to talk out these
feelings with better helps network of
more than 20 000 therapists are ready to
listen and help you after taking a brief
questionnaire you'll be matched with a
therapist whose expertise fits your
unique needs and what's so cool about a
platform like betterhelp where
everything is done remotely is that you
can work with a therapist whose skills
might not otherwise be available in your
area within 48 hours you can start
messaging with your therapist at any
time when you do you'll receive timely
and thoughtful responses in return
additionally you can schedule your
choice of secure phone or video sessions
to receive counseling in real time in my
case i matched with sarah on tuesday had
our first session scheduled by wednesday
and on thursday we talked out some of
the problems that i didn't feel like i
could handle on my own while she didn't
solve everything she definitely made the
things i was dealing with seem a lot
easier to handle and if you and your
therapist aren't a perfect match it's
easy and free to switch to a new one so
join the more than 2 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with better help by visiting
betterhelp.com wisecrack or click the
link in the video description when you
do you'll get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp.com
wisecrack and now back to the show since
the show began barry has descended into
ever more violent antics from murdering
a perfectly nice detective to going on a
needless rampage through a drugstore
house to killing his clients when they
have a sudden change of heart there's no
forgiving jeff not exactly plot lines
conducive to great comedy to understand
how barry keeps delivering the laughs we
need to look at a genre variously called
dark comedy or sick comedy or black
comedy while humans have been laughing
since we were monkeys dark comedy is
something of a newcomer in our species
collective stand-up routine the
co-founder of surrealism andre bruton
coined the phrase lechima noire i.e
black comedy in 1939. he believes the
dark comedy had an inherently modern
sensibility though it had existed in
literature and painting throughout the
ages early dark humor mostly took the
form of didactic moralizing satire
modern dark humor he thought was more
subversive and aggressive and devoid of
moral lessons which kind of sounds a bit
like our favorite show about a hitman
you could bring home to mom but more on
that in a moment but what about an
american culture when it comes to film
you can see dark humor boiling up after
world war ii in works like unfaithfully
yours and monsieur verdu as wheeler
winston dixon writes in post-war america
and the world the old social structures
were crumbling to be replaced by an
emptiness which allowed greater
transgression against perceived
normative rules you saw this in stand-up
comedy where sick comedy like your
favorite dead baby joke started popping
up but the genre really came to a head
in the 60s once the studio system had
breathed its last gasp as dixon notes in
the 1960s themes which had previously
been dealt with only in the most serious
fashion were suddenly subject to
burlesque or parody dark humor dominated
film in the rebellious 60s but mostly
petered out of cinema in the next decade
on tv consensus television i.e
inoffensive shows that tried to appeal
to the widest possible audience
dominated keeping dark comedy mostly off
the air for most of the medium's history
that's with a notable exception of mash
which used a war hospital setting for
dark humor and social critique of
american militarism after mash ended
mainstream 80s television was basically
absent of any similarly dark humor
although glimmers of dark comedy emerged
again in the 90s in the form of popular
programs like seinfeld you know what
they call them soup nazis
the balance of chipper to cynical
programming changed as we moved into the
21st century for two likely reasons one
the rise of cable and later streaming
allowed for greater creativity and
innovation as well as the opportunity to
appeal to more niche audiences i.e
people with twisted senses of humor and
two 911 and the collective trauma
surrounding it much like the aftermath
of world war ii this collective trauma
inspired a whole lot of dark comedy
scholar philip kapansky argues that when
it comes to dark comedy post 911 one of
the genre's most significant roles was
as novacaine by soothing the unpleasant
feelings associated with events like 911
the sick humor of shows like family guy
and south park calloused the public in
such a way that we could approach policy
more rationally dark comedy often
political dominated throughout the
decade but less explicitly political
dark comedy arguably exploded across the
mainstream in the 2000s and 2010s too
think it's always sunny bojack horsemen
curb your enthusiasm baskets the good
place rick and morty archer and so on
journalist rachel roesty argues in the
guardian that the rise of dark comedy
television in the 2010s and the
increasingly surreal dark comedies of
the 2020s owe a lot to the influence of
the weirdos at adult swim and wouldn't
you know we made a whole video just
about that so check it out sometime the
numerous shows that employ dark comedy
today mainly appeal to millennials who
gee wouldn't you know are more depressed
underpaid uncertain about their futures
and so on than previous generations
[Music]
so barry which debuted in 2018 was the
perfect show for a time so now that we
have context for barry's delightfully
twisted humor it's worth looking at some
of the tools it employs to make us laugh
primary among them is something humor
scholars variously call humorous
incongruity or script incompatibility
and yes once someone broke up with me
citing script incompatibility humorous
incongruity describes an irreconcilable
conflict between two opposing things
whose sheer incompatibility incites
laughter importantly incongruities
generally rely on some kind of
transgression of norms we see
incongruity all over barry starting with
the main character himself barry is a
hitman who commits gruesome acts but
he's also weirdly innocent all wide-eyed
and earnest about becoming an actor he's
the perfect version of what j l steinen
calls the comic pathetic hero or
anti-hero who is capable of suggesting
complexity because he has implicitly two
or more sides toward the spectator he's
a hitman and an aspiring mediocre actor
and we respond to him differently
depending on his behavior at any given
moment pathetically though desperate to
be a better actor on stage he's actually
a pretty convincing one in his real life
managing to hide his identity from
everyone around him stein notes that the
anti-hero often tends to assume
universal qualities through the very
individual and contradictory details
that go to make him up we can all relate
on some level to wishing we could trade
one talent in for something more
glamorous even if we've never buried a
dead body on a hill because of his
incongruity of character steinin
explains we respond with sympathy and
criticism both the other characters are
similarly layered sally is a talented
actor with a rich emotional life but
she's also so self-absorbed that it
takes her forever to notice that she's
dating a super duper violent man sally
you're dating violent guy
what hank is a ruthless mobster but he's
also gentle kooky inept and devoted to
barry which makes his attempts to be
intimidating generally quite comedic
i know a tank
when he's confronted by a murderous
barry who deliberates on whether or not
to kill him the supreme tension of the
scene is undercut by hank vomiting in
relief when barry spares him
oh my god
oh my god
i vomited hank is really just the worst
person to be a mobster and the worst
person for the job is almost always the
funniest character hank's not wrong when
he laments that real talk i should not
be manager of client syndicate i should
be manager of hotel chain of towels gene
two is full of incongruities he's
pompous but pathetic he genuinely cares
about his students but briskly charges
them for his advice now i bill
my private classes through another loan
out
so i'm just gonna go and get that ledger
maybe most hilariously he's a revered
and honestly pretty decent acting
teacher who cannot act to save his life
except when it really counts of course
he knows everything barry
he knows you killed janice
i'm so sorry
just let's get in the car and go and
fuchs is a total opportunist and a user
who also is devastated to realize that
barry no longer needs him you're not
even on his mind anymore you're not a
blimp on a case radar these characters
all contain some inner contradiction
what styan calls an incongruity of the
solemn and the ridiculous what's more
because the show doesn't encourage us to
judge any of them we're able to enjoy
their hijinks without pesky things like
morality getting in the way that's in
line with theater critic walter kerr's
contention that as a storyteller it is
better to make a man than to make a
point but barry peddles heavily in
incongruity even beyond the characters
themselves the world of the show is
split between the self-centered
ambitions of aspiring hollywood actors
and the brutality of the mobster
underworld and when those two worlds
meet there's ample opportunity for
moments of pure incongruity like when
barry's marine friends crash a party
hosted by an actor most known for
playing live-action pinocchio both sides
are rendered ridiculous by their
clashing perspectives then there's the
way mob life is presented as with
barry's character brutality is balanced
with innocence like how hank worries
about finding the right heroin table for
his stash house i'm seeing dining room
tables i'm seeing coffee tables but not
sure how to look for the table that i
need
no it's for heroin or how the mobsters
all enjoy kristabal's self-help seminars
cristobal their leader is guru mentioned
highest order like baby tony robbins the
incongruity of mobsters collectively
striving to be more actualized when
their day-to-day job involves murder and
drug trafficking never fails to make us
laugh like the time barry agrees to
train hank's army to pay back his debt
and make them as deadly as he is the
innocent joy the men express as they
train hey boss
did you see is countered by our sickly
knowledge that their new skills can only
be used lethally or take the time in
acting class when barry confesses the
story of his first kill on its own this
story would simply be intense and
disturbing but it's coupled with the
pathetic antics of his not very talented
classmates who try to act out what they
imagine his experience might be the
incongruity between how they imagined
his reaction to killing that he felt
immense guilt oh god
someone is countered by the brutal
reality of how he really felt elated and
ready to bro out
and the acting class's inability to even
conceive of what wartime might be like
is a crucial point much of barry
suggests that by sequestering our
experience with america's recent wars
we're forcing soldiers to bear the
psychological brunt of the country's
foreign policy while the rest of us
remain blissfully unaware more on that
in a moment now notably a common
incongruity in dark comedy is killing a
character and promptly discarding their
body and or narrative they're never to
be heard from again the ramifications of
their death go completely ignored here
the classic incongruity is between the
seriousness of a human life being taken
away and the nonchalance with which that
deadly act is treated think brad pitt's
death in the coen brothers film burn
after reading barry sometimes follows
this role during the first two seasons
there are exceptions though like when a
father mourns his son's death at the
hands of barry's mobster friends or the
way mr cousino is plagued by the loss of
janus cancelled
why um because gene had a full-on
nervous breakdown yesterday and left
still we're often allowed to watch
barry's antics without thinking too hard
about the people he's harming we're even
spared having to actually watch janice
die but in the latest episodes after
fuchs outs barry as the killer to his
victim's various relatives the show
keeps us laser focused on the
consequences of his actions and the pain
he's caused not just to those he
mercilessly killed but to those who
loved his victims this is very unusual
territory for a dark comedy and we think
that might be why some people have
commented that this season feels less
like a straight comedy we'd argue that
the show's ability to be more humane to
its victims than your average dark
comedy while continuing to deliver
laughs is actually proof of its profound
success so what is barry and any dark
comedy effectively doing through its
skewed use of humor a lot of things at
once actually according to scholar
shiara bucaria and luca barra
controversial humor is a way to directly
expose what happens in the world to
engage with the truth to confront and to
respond to a reality that is already in
place but at the same time they note to
be funny such humor necessarily
exaggerates distorts and deforms such
reality for example through hyperbole
irony detachment and emphasis thus
highlighting the inauthenticity behind
representation we'd argue that barry is
using its hyperbolic brutality to
critique the devaluation of human life
in post-9 11 america this devaluation
can be seen both in wars abroad where
soldiers like barry have killed innocent
civilians and domestically as it seems
like no amount of gun violence will make
american politicians take meaningful
action the character of barry a killer
completely desensitized toward violence
while serving in iraq is an avatar for
our country's larger desensitization
toward the real world violence america
has wrought in its war on terror and the
violence that's far too common within
our borders but is the violence we see
in barry serving a larger purpose
scholar kristen a murray would say yes
arguing that dark comedy emerged from
significant shifts in people's
relationship to and understanding of
death in contemporary american society
over the past half century because
previous generations contended with
world wars incurable diseases and
generally shorter life expectancies
death was a natural part of life today
we're far more distanced from death in
part due to higher life expectancies she
argues that this avoidance of death is
entrenched in u.s institutions cultural
practices and personal interactions in
forms like the medical and funeral
industries where only trained
professionals actually confront death on
a daily basis as a result death has
become increasingly medicalized
secularized and mediatized one
consequence of this is that death seems
more conceptual than practical it's like
a concealed possibility rather than a
certainty at the same time americans are
more aware of more deaths than ever
before thanks to the ubiquity of digital
media however this kind of mediated
death is marked by what murray calls a
kind of disembodiment a crafted marketed
sanitized representation of loss rather
than a tangible traumatic physical
demise as such death becomes this big
mysterious thing we don't understand but
are constantly hearing about and that
makes us effing nuts murray argues that
dark comedy is an urgent articulation of
the tension between visible and hidden
aspects of loss scholar paul lewis would
agree writing that the apparent
intensification of cruel humor in recent
years reveals a widely shared desire or
need to better understand and learn to
cope with death when we watch barry off
someone we're contending with those
realities of death we don't typically
encounter in real life and we'd argue
that barry does a better job of forcing
us to confront death than just about any
show on the air by finding darkly funny
ways to inject both drama and comedy
into each individual death looks like
the bolivians made it here before we did
hold on you can't rule other people out
just like that now who's making work
this was bolivians there's the
incongruity between the forgiveness the
two sworn enemies come to in the third
season premiere and barry's deadly
decision not to show them any mercy
there's the tragic irony of ronnie
surviving barry's attack in season two
and killing the jealous cop who put a
hit on him only to be shot dead by
police backup and there's the mirroring
effect of two deaths in the finale one
which we can see but do not hear and one
which we can hear but do not see
[Music]
each one is forcing us to imagine what
someone's final moments on earth really
look or sound like which is pretty metal
and what we fill in the blanks with is
probably more horrifying than any
reality a camera could conjure and of
course there's the constant refrain of
barry declaring after yet another murder
that he's going to stop being violent
starting
now it becomes more darkly funny over
time as barry returns to killing like a
sugar fiend to the nutella jar as we
mentioned some argue that barry has
become too bleak to qualify as a comedy
pointing out that the character has
become completely irredeemable and that
the carnage he's inflicted on the world
is too excessive to allow for laughter
anymore for us this argument assumes
that barry is trying to make anything
resembling a moral point but in the vein
of dark modern comedy it doesn't really
seem to be doing that rather it's as
steinin puts it trying to urge a truth
about the nature of people and things
it's simply offering an unflinching look
at a real phenomenon the contemporary
undervaluing of human life and not
letting us look away for a moment as
dixon writes black comedy at its best
permits the audience not a single refuge
or crutch not even the art itself is
left available as a refuge in which the
reader may seek aesthetic soulless and
meaning there's no comfort to be found
in barry as every laugh is tinged with
darkness and that's what makes it so
good as we've said dark comedy has long
existed in various forms but in modern
days it seems to pop up during times of
political and social turbulence like the
1960s or you know right now barry
unveils the violence of our times while
also showing how it's papered over by
mass media conglomerates who feed us
hackney dishonest narratives no matter
how funny their premise may be but then
she turns him to stone but then she's
still horny so she sucks and then eats
his dick it renders death vivid in a
time when our only exposure to our own
mortality comes via the 24-hour news
cycle at the same time it forces us to
reckon with america's culture of
violence all while being funny to
summarize a socrates line from plato's
symposium real poets use tragedy and
comedy both at once and human life is
experienced as a mix of the tragic and
comedic we'd argue that makes hater and
berg nothing less than contemporary
poets but what do you guys think does
barry straddle tragedy and comedy while
keeping its funny bone intact or has the
show gone too dark for chuckling let us
know in the comments thanks to our
patrons for all your support and be sure
to check out our revamped patreon page
shoot that subscribe button like there's
a tiger in the other room and don't
forget to ring that bell and as always
thanks for watching
later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you